the invitations for social events just
keep pouring into my phone and and stuff
they really do Wendy Williams is single
and may be ready to mingle
on Wednesdays the Wendy Williams Show
the 54 year old jokes that she's been
getting a lot of attention following her
split from her husband Kevin hunter who
allegedly fathered a child with his
mistress I was minding my own business
last night I was reading my book you
know you know I love to read and all of
a sudden my cell phone rings and it's DJ
booth asking me out for dinner booth DJs
Williams talk-show just at that time I
got a knock at my door my foie gras and
ting were delivered so I'm like booth or
food so I set up my meal while I told
booth I'll see you over the weekend pick
me up on time then then then I get back
to reading my book and my phone rings
again this time William said it was
Breakfast Club radio host
Charlamagne tha God the two have known
each other for years and used to work
together
Charlamagne wanted to take me for dinner
so he says the night and I said and he
says the time and I said I can't go I'm
going out with booth for dinner
[Applause]
so Charlemagne says well I know booth
why don't we both take you out I said
look I'm reading and I have my food here
why don't you call boof and you also did
he call you booth all right good so uh
okay so I've got a double date Williams
filed for divorce from Hunter last week
after 21 years of marriage it's so crazy
because now my business is your business
[Music]
got a farness on Tuesday hunter broke
his silence in a statement to ET saying
in part quote I am NOT proud of my
recent actions and take full
accountability and apologize to my wife
my family and her amazing fans